[Music]
there's a passenger who was on a flight
on quote-unquote that
breast fed a cat and wouldn't put it
back in the carrier
back in the carrier titty
she's got two cat carriers
they're that much she's got that much
titty that she needs to declare both
heavies dude
for kitties.com it was a lactating
mother
i i don't even know if that detail is
there but yes a human mother
pulled out her tit yes and a cat started
sucking it yes and then one was asked by
a flight attendant to put the kid put
that away she didn't
put that away is that illegal oh well i
know that you're supposed to have the
cat in the you're supposed to have the
pet in the carrier for the whole flight
so is that the technicality that you
know it wasn't the breast uh that needed
to go back in the carrot at the very
least yeah it was the cat that needed to
go back people are sneezing and [ __ ]
they're like yeah she put the titty
through the the cage no i doubt it she
should have she probably should have i
think it was out of the carrier i think
that cat was [ __ ] sucking on it like
that hamster drink water water thing oh
no with a little ball bearing yeah that
looks a little i didn't need to imagine
anything
i didn't know cats like titty milk like
that i didn't know it's [ __ ]
teeth were gonna [ __ ] claw and make
the titty bleed oh and you got then they
got like sandpaper tongue
they do which might be kind of nice this
is a new mother too she's lactating
where's her [ __ ] newborn i have no
idea no she could be one of those like
uh whoever lacks
convince yourself like there's those
like um it's like the there's that
medical condition where you convince
yourself that you're pregnant and then
you're just placebo lactato yes
the latin word for it yeah placebo
that's pretty good it's a thing though
it sounds like a some kind of burrito
it's like a lion king song
[Laughter]
what a wonderful thing
so a viral screen grab
purportedly shows an aircraft
communications addressing and reporting
systems message from delta airlines
flight
to atlanta detailing the bizarre
occurrence on the plane message
seemingly written by the pilot indicates
that the woman refused to put the cap
back in the carrier pond request so they
called for delta's redcoat ground team
to bring in backup
and the message reads
require redcoat meet ac pax or passenger
in c13a is breastfeeding a cat and will
not put back put cat back in its carry
when fa aka flight attendant request it
so they haven't taken off yet or they
just they're in the air i'm sure they're
[ __ ] in the air and they're about to
land and then they're like hey we need
some backup because this lady's [ __ ]
oh damn yeah that is pretty crazy we got
some crazy people on planes nowadays
because it's weird because it's like i
don't have a problem with people like
breastfeeding and stuff like because i
know that's a big thing where it's like
oh you know yeah why should you have to
like go somewhere if you're coming you
know if you're trying to feed your kid i
don't know the cat thing's a little
weird
is that against any kind of like pet
regulation like bestiality type [ __ ] is
that like it's considered animal abuse
i'm sure that could be a form of abuse
maybe maybe it depends on circumstance
maybe it's abuse not to feed your cat
but that's wild though but then that
means she probably trained the cat
probably it's like a normal thing for
the cat at this point right oh you're a
cat lover
you have cats i don't have i don't
breastfeed like coming at you like
lovers
i don't know i mean i mean we're talking
about [ __ ] beats
don't put that on me do you empathize
with cats right like you [ __ ] with cats
heavy so it's [ __ ] with cats or [ __ ]
no not [ __ ] them
really scary i'm saying that very normal
you guys keep flipping my mouth he's a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
guy milk
excuse me this question was not as good
as my question milk yeah that's a good
one
like your dick milk
yeah you heard dick milk your cat it's
white
don't answer any of these it's not as
much as teddy milk you don't get as much
according to the article i give [ __ ]
cats my dick milk
they wrote about you in the article
that's how the article ends
anthony lee gives his cat dick milk and
refuses to stop how do you how would if
you sat next to her how would you feel
this lady was breastfeeding you're not
breastfeeding i'm like hey do you want
some dish meal
yeah what if you're the right answer
betting a cat suck your dick on the
plane do you stop your cat that's crazy
stop your cat from do you stop your cat
when it tries to second let's first of
all let's bring the attention back to uh
the very infamous the one and only bar
kwon's threesome
oh yeah your dog with dogs wait say that
again yeah this dog lick his [ __ ]
butt
no uh so i used to live in like a like a
back house like a garage
and then and our mattress was on the
floor
so when me and jill were having sex my
dog came and like
oh guess i was in a threesome
i'm a player like that you just check
that off the liz you didn't go like whoa
[ __ ] it
oh i did of course we were both just
laughing it was like what the [ __ ]
that's pretty tight though that's cool
congrats man he's like ah what the [ __ ]
do it again you're a dog lover he's a
cat lover have you been licked by a cat
before their tongue is like razor blades
so why would you want that on your
[ __ ] nipple i didn't [ __ ] say i
wanted it on my nipple why are you
asking me with those [ __ ] eyes you
didn't say that
i thought that's what you're kind of
like you know going to
i felt like that was like ages ago i
thought that was exactly what you said
if you're the air marshal on the flight
are you like is it my time to [ __ ]
just jump on this [ __ ] or are you like
he's not that dangerous though
i can't justify this yeah you'd be like
just trigger happening he's got your
hand on the gun on [ __ ] right right
you gave him such a volatile
personality he keeps reaching for it and
he's like
but she keeps doing it like they're
picking out the air marshall like the
guy and the [ __ ] like while they're
testing everyone there's one guy that's
just like
they're like that guy we want that guy
on the [ __ ] flight right are they
supposed to not look like the air
marshal he's just like
oh he's the guy that's like pretending
he's sleeping he's like
the worst pretended sleeper ever just
like
with like one eye open the entire flight
lady put that cat back
i'm trying to give orders but disguise
them as like sleep murmurs
put your kidney back in your shirt no i
wish isis would but
i wish isis would
got a [ __ ] cat bomb on this airline
oh man that has to be illegal right you
can't be breastfeeding no cat uh i don't
know i don't know that's the thing it's
like uh but you know like the argument
is like oh that you're mistreating the
cat the cat's like somehow like being
mystery but imagine this is like a very
like healthy like fat cat it's just like
a super
they're just like look at how terrible
they're chewing this cat this black cat
just hella milk all over
this [ __ ] like it's gluttonous
you are doing this in abundance and not
out of necessity yeah and that's a
problem it's got to be wrong yeah
there's a judge specifically for these
cases yeah
he's like i don't get to come out very
often when i do
speaking of is it illegal though i don't
know but i assume anything that happens
the first time
is not illegal you think this is the
first thing murder no i'm just saying
that i did anything i heard it the first
time i think murder they were like bam
they're like oh murder the first time
imagine murder the first time that it
happened human history yeah cain and
abel that got written about in the bible
as being wrong they got punished
for that there was no law but people
felt wrong about it there was no law
though right but people probably looked
at that like hey
maybe don't do that yeah yeah people
were like now we should deem this
illegal yeah i guess like you just hit
bob with a rock bro
i don't know if that's right right
that's what i'm saying if like if this
is the first instance dude a feline
breastfeeding
i can't say it's illegal i gotta at
least be like she's a pioneer case
number two there could there should be
an answer no she you know what she's
brave
so is the cat oh the cat
she said you know what i'm gonna
breastfeed my baby and not get shamed
for it that's what she said that's a
process too she must uh yes well then i
wonder if there's any laws in the book
in the book of law of crimes that have
never happened
crimes that never happened not yet like
stuff that they made lost
are there any of those in there where
they're like oh that's got to be this is
illegal but no one's ever done it but
it's illegal
there's got to be like one type of
instance like let's say like murder the
first time it's like uh this person got
stabbed right they're like okay well how
do we make that law so it's illegal to
stab somebody it's like but what if it's
in self defense it's illegal to stab
somebody unless it's in self defense
it's like but what if like you deserve
that you were defending yourself but you
had just committed this crime you know
honestly yeah they instigated it yeah
like they probably have to like take a
basis or a foundation for something and
then like create every [ __ ] like
graph chart around it in order to get
really creative so i would assume that
some of the best
lawyers or law writers have to be the
most [ __ ] up people with imagination
in order to imagine this crime
and then they make the law after because
it's like which is more likely
right there's like yeah there's like
manslaughter there's like different
kinds what if there's just wild [ __ ]
that can't even be done yet and they're
just like no just in case like you can't
you kill a cloud from another region
and put it in [ __ ] this is gonna be
stealing clouds oh that's illegal like
stuff that's like you can't do it but
they're like no but we need to make sure
yeah like airspace or some [ __ ] like
your building can't be more than five
floors i own that airspace and you're
gonna block mine you got space law yet
space law right space long because we
got space force technically not yet
though right because right
it's supposed to be a neutral space but
i mean it's not even considered like
international waters it's like not even
yeah there's no wild it's not it's it
can't make derogatory comments on other
planets
no
you just or your ship would just ship
all the races off to like
to like mars and they just make like a
racist planet where they just dude and
it thrives and we're jealous
that's realistically what every other
planet already is and that's what earth
is it's like they've shipped us down
here
yeah we probably are we're the rejects
we were breastfeeding cats and [ __ ] we
were an alien experiment and they're
just like ugh we [ __ ] up and then they
ran away yeah
they left like specifically ran yeah
[Music]
[Music]
you